c'est dans ce jardin situé près de pont
sur yonne que des balles de pistolet ont
été retrouvés le 21 janvier des bases
identiques à celles retrouvées dans le
corps d'andré kerckhof sept mois plus
tôt suite à cette perquisition
le suspect âgé de 50 ans est passé aux
aveux pour ses voisins
'l'annonce a été un choc on a un
assassin un côté nous ça fait peur je le
dis tout de suite ça c'est triste
déjà pour la famille de monsieur qu'est
tués et pirro de famille aussi pascal
acot mairie à 15 sa fille alors
aujourd'hui la pauvre petite mer hachée
triste âgé de 70 ans andré kerkhove
vivait une paisible retraite à 100
certain le 27 juin 2018
il est retrouvé mort à son domicile son
corps est atteint de deux balles selon
les déclarations de l'auteur présumé
l'assassinât aurait étudié le matin du
23 juin armé d'un colt 45
le suspect aurait tiré à deux reprises
sur la victime pour l'entourage du
retraité ce crime reste incompréhensible
j'ai connu la v5 en a le dd à l'horreur
il a toujours vu et vécu une vie de
travailleur et honnête et tout moi je ne
vois pas pourquoi on a dû se passer
quelque chose d'extraordinaire fonds
convient de le faire ce qu'on lui a fait
un ça c'est quand même grave ça si le
suspect a reconnu les faits la question
du mobile restent encore floues suite à
ses aveux
william vincent a été mise en examen
pour assassinat déjà condamné en juillet
dernier à deux ans de prison ferme pour
violences avec arme
le quinquagénaire reste donc en prison
une peine qu'il purge ici à la maison
d'arrêt d'auxerre